hi guys it's silver at again and today
I'm actually going to cover some simple
foliage and other things especially
around this area so first of all I want
to give a basic explanation coasters
aren't just things to ride there are
also plenty of people I like to look at
coasters you'll have benches around them
all kinds of stuff will happen they're
also part of the scenery they need to
really work with the rest of the scenery
and the foliage and stuff like that so I
definitely want to transform this little
area into an area where people can walk
around the paths and perhaps even have a
restaurant somewhere place benches and
other cool things but you have to be
able to actually see the rollercoaster
now what in real life is very common is
just some antique grass stuff around the
rollercoaster
now this is very boring and I don't like
doing this I don't want to go there I
don't want to do what Six Flags does so
I do want to add foliage to this thing
but it's very minimal and very low to
make sure that you can actually see it
very well and it does have some cloth
interaction so what I kind of want to go
for is some claw is some grass foliage
some slight perhaps even flowers and
some simple bushes now I'm going to open
a couple foliage that's because I really
love just mixing sets and just seeing
what's the best thing to do say I'm
going to open agent sensation and now
this doesn't make seem to make much
sense but this that's got some amazing
create moodle's that can actually work
as really nice bushes so I think I'm
just gonna add those on the sides over
there
smooth style some some small clusters of
small bushes here and there I do want to
keep the grass around the roller-coaster
I definitely don't want to turn this
into a big forest and have too much too
much foliage going on around it so I
think that's already enough of those
things might actually also try and use a
different version of this its release
and foliage along the rocks will also be
nice and I works out pretty well and
it's gonna place that around that
so that's pretty good and one important
aspect of adding low simple foliage is
actually cross so that's one important
thing that I want to cover in this
episode and I'm actually going to start
with the cross
now this may be doesn't make sense but I
don't know this it's not really a way to
do it you can add bushes first or you
can add grass first it doesn't really
matter as long as you do the granary
though before you actually do the light
robbery just because of practical
reasons it's easier to do it and it's
easier to see what you're doing so I
think I'm just going to add some small
lush grass from peanut Botticelli's
beach pants set and this is really one
of my favorite sets out there also and
by the way remember to keep some open
space over here I couldn't forgot that -
to add a cue in later on okay but anyway
this is one of my favorite sets ever and
there aren't any grass sets in
rollercoaster going through that video a
couple betta sets but so far neither of
them has has been a success simply
because the fact that it's hard to make
good looking realistic grass in this
game and if you do make it it's gonna
like the game a lot and basically melt
your computer and you don't want that to
happen so none of the sets actually
turned out to be a success but this this
beat across that actually does work
really nicely as you can see you can
just add small little clusters orbits
I'm actually gonna use this bar spring
now to spell it out or more in a more
natural way and you can kind of place it
around the roller coaster in some small
clusters and it'll definitely look very
nice it's meant for beaches and stuff
like that but it turns out that it kind
of works for a grassy plains and stuff
like that as well so I definitely pretty
much used isn't all of my coasters it's
really great to just have lying around
around the coaster track on the ground
so that's really great and do make sure
though to place this in clusters it will
look more natural if you just place it
evenly spread around the entire thing it
will sometimes just look too man-made
nature isn't perfect so you shouldn't
make perfect foliage it shouldn't look
kind of random okay so also this is
something to add around rocks sometimes
just slightly brush that around that and
as you can see it it definitely makes
the entire thing look a lot more natural
and appealing right away and it
definitely makes the grass look more
realistic instantly but as you can also
see it's still a bit boring it's not
much going on over here and I do want to
keep this area clear for the path but
otherwise it's not really anything going
on so I also like to add flowers that
kind of have that very natural feel if
okay one thing that I need to talk about
is flowers yes many people add flowers
everywhere don't ever do that only add
flowers next to paths where people can
actually maintain them more people can
actually what are the flowers because
otherwise they're gonna die you'll never
have roses and stuff like that in the
middle of nowhere
underneath the coaster that's pretty
much impossible to maintain your real
life but you can add though is wild
looking flowers so some of those simple
flowers that some people would call weed
but there's weed and yeah I just like to
add those things sometimes it gives some
color to their foliage without making it
look too unrealistic now I think that
these things don't actually conform yep
because as you can see many bushes don't
actually conform and I like my bushes to
conform because as you can see if you
have a slight slope you can't actually
get a good placement for it or either
float or disappear into the ground so I
wouldn't recommend that now I do know
however that gardening too has one
really cool looking fern or at least I
think this kind of looks like a phone to
me and what I'm not that much of an
expert that does conform actually and I
really like just using this here in
there so I'm just gonna scatter this
around pretty good
and then there is Asian sensation which
is yet another satisfy and seven I'm
trying to find it though think it's in
Adventure theme it probably is our way
it's actually not even a theme never
mind
but it wasn't even an Asian sensation
has the crepe myrtles that I just
explained but it also has some other
cool stuff like this these cherry trees
are really nice if you have a Asian
coaster generally but I found out that
some of these trees actually work with
Mediterranean themes as well has this
amazing tree in it that I like to use
sometimes I'm actually using this pot
thing as well and this thing works
really well for a small bush like trees
so I think I'm gonna use that over there
yeah definitely it's definitely got that
nice texture over here and as you might
be able to tell right now all of this
foliage does look kind of warm it
doesn't really look European or North
American I am going for a Mediterranean
slash maybe even Florida kind of theme
so might even add some palm trees in the
end not too many though but I'll talk
about that later on but for now this
looks pretty cool now there's one other
sat which I think which is jumbled
jumbled yet another side by an 7 and 7
is amazing shadow 2 and 7 for his
awesome foliage I know this is quite
going to work out not really but the
thing with this set is this set has got
small round things that actually conform
very low poly so you can use them pretty
much as much as you want and to kind of
add some stuff to the ground without
actually raising it up too much and it's
easy to place it definitely looks good
if you place them in some nice clusters
so I always like adding those as well so
I'm just gonna place these everywhere
let's see yeah that looks pretty good
sometimes these can also form a border
around other foliage like that so that's
pretty cool and I think they're not
weeds I don't know if those actually
conform do they kind of looks like they
do yeah they do actually oh that's a
really great thing to add then I don't
know why fraps is linking right now I'm
sorry for the the light I see that it's
on 13 FPS okay it's gone nevermind
that was strange okay so these things
are also really nice to add
like I said before if you do have angle
slopes always and foliage that is at
least conforming you don't want to have
floating things and things that
disappear into the ground so sets like
these who have enough conforming bushes
and shrubs and grass things to basically
make this all look nice you can add
these Japanese things sorry and damn I
shouldn't record when I was at home
anyway I kind of actually add this
summer ones as well with them I don't
know if that makes sense
looks good though some ice box now I see
that I am already nearly over using the
foliage so this is definitely almost
enough I should definitely stop at this
point you don't want to turn the Grunch
shrubbery into one big festal various
kinds of things so I think that this is
pretty much good enough for the moment
so yeah that's it for the foliage I
think this looks pretty cool it's just
some simple foliage I'm actually gonna
do a quick one right see what this looks
like from within the coaster come on
mind do that now one more thing to talk
about is some people also like adding
pebbles and there are pebble sets
actually let's explode 1% let's say
something that actually has good pebbles
the only problem with that is it's got
shadow problems and I do want to have my
shadows so you can add pebbles you can
experiment with that but it's not
necessary so I decided to not do that
right now and as you can see this
foliage is kind of minimalistic that's
not too much of it but it it kind of
forms a nice accent around the ride and
it makes sure that you it makes sure
that you get that nice little grassy
feel and it also kind of gives away that
Mediterranean / subtropical vibe so
that's really nice so that's it for this
episode thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed it and I'm sorry for me
being terrible and having a call and all
that but anyway on to the next episode
where I hope to get some path work done
actually change the texture of that and
talk about that some more so till then